[Musique]
il
tous
[Musique]
non
en
[Musique]
on
en
comment
oh
non
[Musique]
on
pour
ans
ban
on
non
[Musique]
tant de remous
non
c'est tout
ok ce que ça marche parce que vous
m'entendez est ce que le son est correct
si longtemps que j'ai pas fait de stream
et ses
habitudes ses meilleurs fois c'était
monsieur fille qui gérait tout
ce que vous m'entendez ce que le son est
correct
et bouger sur ma chaise aussi
je crois on pourra le laisser la musique
d'ascenseur à ça
je vais essayer de laisser la musique de
ce que je peux faire c'est
[Musique]
ainsi
bord
[Musique]
non
ok
cool bon bah bonjour à tous bienvenue
aujourd'hui pour un petit tutoriel
tournesol parce que tournesol les de
retour en ligne après plein de
péripéties et maintenant c'est une
équipe un peu plus solide c'est ça roule
beaucoup plus et donc la première chose
c'est je veux aller sur le site tressol
points à payer pour orgue aussi ça
marche mais
[Musique]
rivière propre
tournesol
donc qu'il ya un le gros gros gros
projet vraiment sur lequel je traîne en
ce moment c'est vraiment le truc le plus
plus important que je pense à faire
alors le truc le plus cool et depuis pas
mal de temps en temps on a pas mal j'ai
pas mal de
lancer une association avec des amis du
cookie maintenant l'association
tournesol dont je suis président avec
d'autres membres
dans mon lit et hayden pour en savoir
plus une section about c'est pas parce
que je suis allé à parfois vous y allez
ça ressemble plus à ça et donc une
section
c'est qu'elle apparaîtrait ici
c'est pas terrible
si un propos llc en français traduction
en français à vient de sortir j'ai pas
trop le temps de tout voir sur le faire
si on française mais version française
donc que vient de sortir il est aussi en
anglais ce qui sont plus anglophones et
changer la langue ici et donc sur la
section à propos vous avez
plus d'informations sur vous voulez sur
tournesol donc qu'est ce que tous nos
sols donc c'est ainsi une plateforme
libre et open source dont le but est
d'identifier les vidéos d'utilité
publique de grande qualité de manière
collaborative en s'appuyant sur le
jugement de contributeurs donc des
contributeurs comme par exemple vous
dans le tchat vous pouvez créer un
compte sur tournesol et je vais faire
cette vidéo pour voir juste accompagner
les gens dans cette démarche
le but c'est de rendre les algorithmes
d'aujourd'hui et de demain plus
robustement bénéfique à grande échelle
donc elle fait en sorte que les
algorithmes en particules de
recommandations recommande des choses de
qualité mais on pense aussi que tout ce
qui est fait là sera réutilisable pour
ensuite concevoir toutes sortes d'autres
algorithmes personne de traitement du
langage qui soit beaucoup plus
robustement bénéfique et il ya pas mal
de liens si vous voulez en savoir plus
nous il ya le white paper pour les gens
qui sont un peu un peu technique qui est
un article qui
date un petit peu maintenant lorsqu'ils
date de 20 ans du 29 mai 2021 donc ça
fait
enfin pas encore un an mais il ya des
choses qui sont dites ici qui ont un peu
évolué bon ça c'est une bonne
introduction quand même ma vision
globale on espère qu'on aura mise à jour
bientôt parce qu'il ya pas mal de deux
nouveaux trucs vraiment cool a montré sa
ses papiers sur arcade gratuitement
disponible
sinon bah y'a le wiki alors lucky pas
forcément ultra jour ya un travail à
faire sur le wiki mais il ya beaucoup
d'informations beaucoup de liens
beaucoup de sources et d'ailleurs y est
beau look qui est pas le vent peut que
bon utilise et
c'est celui là
donc
pacy développeurs voient ça mais ça sera
un petit point à corriger il n'y a pas
mal informations sur lucky énormément de
liens c'est vraiment écrit comme un
outil dans le multimédia
beaucoup d'informations peut-être un peu
trop mieux ne pas commencer par ça pour
les sections plus développeurs il ya un
lien vers le github qui est open source
en licence
gpl gpl et donc ça c'est pour le code le
base de données mots envers un peu plus
tard il ya en dessous
on a un serveur discorde si vous êtes
intéressé par contribuer notamment si
vous voulez contribuer niveau de code
par exemple dont il ya un serveur
discorde e pour le faire puma et green
dean si vous voulez relayée en compte
twitter également
tournesol apple compte twitter et même
des bottes twitter m'a fait jouer c'est
d'aller les voir alors j'ai tout des log
et pour être sûr de révéler aucune
données personnelles le concernant ne
sais pas si sur twitter si je tape
directement tournesol hop
ça c'est le compte de tournesol
de
le compte twitter de tournesol est
vrai pour les autres délires mais aussi
le tournesol bottes qui régulièrement
intuit les bonnes vidéos de tournesol et
ça c'est le bot français
c'est tournesol bottes fr et si vous
avez vu surtout une seule botte c'est la
version anglophone qui demande suite des
vidéos parmi les tops de tournesol
[Musique]
l'objectif de tournesol c'est de
construire les fondations d'une
gouvernance algoet microbus c'est
bénéfique à grande échelle c'est un peu
des gros mots mais c'est vraiment la
mission fin c'est vraiment le travail de
recherche qui me fascine plus
le pouls cool qui existe
je pense commencer c'est un peu la
combinaison de beaucoup de deux de ses
resigned forum ski et paysagisme
intelligence artificielle démocratie
tout ça ensemble pour faire un système
qui répond au besoin de gouverner
collaborativement ce que font les algoé
de recommandations à grande échelle
nous ça passe par de la sensibilisation
à la crise globale de l'information
sais pas s'il y en a qui ont vu le film
tente lock-up ici mais voilà ça fait
partie de ces choses
pardon le deuxième point c'est le
développement de la plateforme
collaborative donc tourner au sol pour
l'évolution et la recommandation de
contenus en ligne et puis à travers de
la recherche
beaucoup de recherches sur les titres
des algorithmes en construisant
notamment une base de données fiable de
jugement humain c'est ce que permet
tournesol d'avoir ces données qui vont
un peu plus sécurisé beaucoup plus
sécurisée sur des jugements humains on
va chercher ensuite à généraliser enfin
déjà calculé agrégé ensuite
tranquillement mon futur arrêt
généralisé pour ensuite savoir ce que
les algorithmes devrait recommander
d'après la communauté l'ensemble des
contributeurs de tournesol en
encourageant bien sûr un maximum de
personnes à contribuer à tourner seul
pour que ce jugement race monde autant
que possible un jugement de l'ensemble
de l'humanité
le but à long terme
qui fabrique et on sonne donc comme il
l'a dit donc non ça c'est un projet
extrêmement transparent dont vous pouvez
voir sur github nous tous ceux qui ont
contribué
il ya aussi beaucoup de documentation à
travers le 8i
notamment puis sur le discorde sur la
vision du projet les différentes
priorités
différents objectifs et ainsi de suite
livre auquel le fabuleux chantier qui
parle de ça il ya nouveau livre
s'appelle smart poupe
qu'ils essaient de sensibiliser à tout
cela et de mettre les ingrédients et je
passe paul et la fin de de smartbook
mais il ya un lien avec tournesol très
très très très fort alors que personne
qui est derrière ces deux projets la
même personne et donc tout seul et avant
tout ceux portés par l'association
tournesol
qui est une organisation à but non
lucratif basée à lausanne en suisse qui
cherche des noms donc
[Musique]
c'est un peu plus tard on parle un peu
plus tard
donc les trois co fondateurs
il ya un mois vous prennez sait si vous
êtes là il ya lui faut qu'on le
trésorier de l'association qui
aujourd'hui aussi le principal product
owner un peu cette terminologie donc
c'est un peu lui qui guide le plus le
développement et à prioritisation des
nouvelles fonctionnalités sur sur la
plateforme et hayden john gaulle
le secrétaire qui
également et puis aussi product owner
est qui qui va pas mal accompagné
lui dans la priorisation des tâches et
qui aussi fait quelques trucs très cool
de de l'analyse des données que l'on a
déjà
et tant d'autres aujourd'hui mais dans
une prochaine vidéo
le principal développeur quand même créé
un
ingénieur de recherche de le pfl
il ya un partenariat du coup avec
l'école polytechnique fédérale il ya peu
évident qu'il ya des liens avec le pfl
sachant que
je suis
employé de le pfl et lui et à eagan sont
des anciens de le pfl qui sont diplômés
docteur en informatique et master en
sciences
et donc avec le pfl donc on adrien maty
sarr qu'ingénieur de recherche dans le
laboratoire de calcul distribué qui est
pas arrêtée il ya 20 celui où je me
trouve et qui qu'il y de quelle
technique wakili de le développement de
la plateforme en collaboration avec un
nouvel employé qui a pas encore été
rajoutés
roman
qui sera là sont bientôt rajouter à
cette page un des partenariats avec deux
entreprises pour les conseils d'un côté
dans le programme dans un programme
texte fort good qui nous accompagnent et
keanu également
un développeur et en
manager de projet
un jour par semaine en pot pour le
développement de la plateforme on est
extrêmement reconnaissants au pays
conseillent à g a fait beaucoup de
progrès est également incluse
technologies qui nous ont également
beaucoup accompagné attendant manière
d'un ingénieur de chez eux qui nous a
beaucoup accompagnés
sont ils pas ingénieur il est docteur en
informatique
ancien de l'hôtel fait également et et
il nous a beaucoup accompagné notamment
dans leur déploiement dans la réécriture
du code et
nous accompagne aussi maintenant dans la
gestion du projet et puis on a aussi une
armée de faim pas mal de bénévoles
qui nous aident et également beaucoup
dans le développement du projet et puis
le gros objectif de tourner au sol
surtout à court terme c'est vraiment
cette base de données publique qu'on est
en train de construire sur le jugement
que vous pourriez faire sur quelle vidéo
vous pensez être davantage d'utilité
publique
c'est si vous lui faites ces jugements
de façon publique on va voir ce que ça
veut dire ça fait une base de données
publique et on espère vraiment que cette
base de données publique grossistes
beaucoup à la gare 2500 utilisateurs
avec 9000 comparaison de 3000 vidéo
c'est déjà quelque chose à dire mais
bien sûr pour que ce soit vraiment un
impact il faudrait que
également ce chiffre aille dans les
millions ça serait vraiment bien parce
que si on atteint les millions là ça
fait vraiment une base de données
sérieuses et le but c'est notamment que
cette base de données sérieuses soient
ensuite réutilisés par les chercheurs
parce que si vous me suivez un petit peu
sur twitter ou sur youtube vous savez
peut-être que j'ai beaucoup de
frustration envers certaines entreprises
de l'ateq que je ne pas le nommer ici
mais mes vidéos favret google et
facebook donc j'ai été nommé et et
d'autre mais j'ai aussi beaucoup de
frustration envers la communauté de la
recherche académique aujourd'hui qui je
trouve n'est pas assez orienté vers les
questions de sécurité et d'éthique des
algorithmes est encore beaucoup trop
porté sur les questions de performance
est la raison pour cela c'est souvent
que on va pouvoir publier aujourd'hui on
chercheurs ont souvent prendre une base
de données publique faire tourner des
algorithmes et s'est montré que dans ses
algorithmes sont meilleurs que ceux
développés par les autres chercheurs et
aujourd'hui bas les bases de données
publiques et enfin une base de données
qui sont utilisés bas se sont détruits
que soient assez assez joué à ses
propres connaître des chiffres dans ton
dans une image ça serait que ces minis
cités mais bon aujourd'hui cette base de
données ouais elle a beaucoup de limites
et au soin ce sont des données pas du
tout sécurisé
et ce qu'on aimerait c'est à voir cette
base de données sécurisée qui parle de
jugement éthique avec des considérations
qui viennent forcément avec ça par
exemple la présence de faux comptes par
exemple le fait qu'ils aient des
comportements stratégiques
potentiellement parmi les contributeurs
le fait qu'il va avoir la peau les
créations peu fait qu'ils aient des
communautés différentes et qui est qui
sont plus ou moins représentées dans
base de dave à toutes ces questions qui
pour moi sont vraiment les questions
critiques de sécurité et d'éthique des
algorithmes abbas on sait les premiers
tic qui j'espère seront soulevées par
l'existence de cette base de données
publique et le fait que chercheurs vont
essayer de faire quelque chose avec sa
base de données publiques et donc c'est
vraiment critique aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est vraiment le gros objectif de
tournesol dans les deux années à venir
c'est de concevoir une énorme base de
données publique qui va complètement
motivé la recherche et qui va peut-être
changer la manière dont on parle de
qu'est ce qu'il aurait fait plus qu est
ce qu une anti vont certes ciel qu'est
ce que machine learning qu'est ce que la
machine learning sécurisé qu'est ce que
doit faire c'est l'observent ses
algorithmes à grande échelle et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est extrêmement
important qu'un maximum parmi vous
contribuer c'est pour que ces questions
soient prises au sérieux par les années
par les académiques parce que si elles
sont pris par les un sérieux pas
académique y aura beaucoup plus de
pression ensuite déjà beaucoup plus
d'outils pour pouvoir mieux audités tous
à mieux comprendre tout ça et ensuite y
aura beaucoup plus facilement plus de
pression sur le privé est sûre et sur
les institutions publiques pour ensuite
mettre beaucoup plus d'investissements
dans la recherche sur la sécurité et
l'éthique et comment est-ce qu'on
gouverne collaborativement les algues
aux fondations
c'était un peu l'introduction est au sol
j'espère que c'était assez clair et
maintenant ce que je vais faire c'est
créer un compte sur son sol vous montrer
comment on fait rien de très fins et
très standard mais si vous accompagner
et puis après on va voir comment en tant
que contributeur on contribue et
questions les questions qu'on se pose
est pourquoi est-ce que je pense que ce
sont des questions intéressant que ça à
fournir des données en tout cas
intéressante pour la recherche
académique
mais avant de cela je reviens sur la
page d'accueil de tournesol la page
d'accueil de tournesol c'est ça ça nous
dit
automation club rhétique de contenus
samedi un peu qu'est-ce que tournesol et
puis il ya quelque chose qui nous dit
utiliser l'extension alors parce qu'en
effet il ya une extension associé à
thompson vous pouvez aller cliquer
dessus donc là je suis sur firefox du
coup ça me renvoie sur cette page de
firefox vous êtes sûr comme ça on verra
on verra
notre page avec un autre une autre
extension et vous pouvez du coup ajouté
l'extension
kalou était l'extension bon ça donne et
droit donc ça permet à tout un sol
d'accéder aux données pour les domaines
les situe du domaine où youtube.com voir
pourquoi c'est important pour nous
d'avoir accès à ces données pour faire
ensuite des recommandations sur sur
cette page
accéder aussi à vos données pour tourner
seul point ap comment les jugements
confrères de choses accéder à vos
données via l'api deux tours seulement
savent quelque chose sur youtube.com et
accèder à l'activité du navigateur
pendant la navigation sur youtube.com et
sur tournesol
vous devez ajouter hockey
et là du coup vous avez quand même j'ai
installé du coût de l'extension donc
j'ai un petit nouveau qui apparaît et ça
ça va faire quoi ça va faire que en
particulier si maintenant je vais sur
youtube.com
si je vais sur youtube.com
voilà
hélas ce que vous voyez ces convois des
recommandations faites par tourner au
sol sur la page d'accueil de youtube bah
maintenant vous avez vous pouvez voir
que ya des vidéos qui ont été
recommandés en fait une ronde par la
communauté des contributeurs de
tournesol agrégé via les algorithmes de
tournesol et donc
par exemple on va voir cette vidéo
un autre truc qui va apparaître ici
c'est un bouton régulateur qui va vous
permettre de dire à tourner au sol que
vous voulez notez cette vidéo
[Musique]
et donc si vous cliquez sur ce bouton
bah ça va bon là ça va pas marcher parce
que vous n'êtes pas encore s'il faut
être longue et surtout nos sols pour que
tout le monde sache que vous ajoutez
cette vidéo à votre compte et que vous
avez noté avec votre compte du coup la
vidéo surtout nous sommes donc c'est une
façon de de choisir ensuite qu'elle en
fait en étant dans l'expérience habituel
de youtube de choisir quelle vidéo vous
allez ensuite vous pouvoir noter sur sur
[Musique]
du coup
donc ok vous savez maintenant j'ai
l'extension et ensuite la poussée une
chose c'est de commencer à comparer de
participer et pour ça il faut créer un
compte sur console soit se connecter sur
ton si vous étiez un comtois vous pouvez
vous inscrire sur tournesol est donc là
bas il faut entrer une adresse email du
coup mon art j'ai créé une adresse email
pour l'occasion qui s'appelle tournesol
pointe est apte
proton mail comme
l'avouent peut choisir un nom
d'utilisateur alors selon l'utilisateur
sera public donc
fait attention à ce sera public tout par
exemple d'appeler sa tournée seul test
alors suite vous vous créez un mot de
passe
dans son mot de passe
des quelques pas
avec l'arche
et ensuite vous vouliez entendre lire
les conditions d'utilisation et
politiques de confidentialité
alors je vais pas je peux pas les lire
ici parce que c'est un peu long mais en
gros ça dit comment les données sont
utilisées ça explique beaucoup cette
mission que l'on a de partager les
données pour la recherche lorsque vous
mettez public mais bien sûr si vous
mettez les données en privé seuls
tournesol les connaîtra et s'était donné
qu'on pourront être utilisés malgré tout
si vous me mettez des comparaisons pour
ensuite faire des recommandations
bon ça coûte et de principes financiers
des gens que j'inscris
m alors ça ça va ensuite m'envoyer un
email à cette adresse là du coup faut
que je me connecte à protons mail bon
c'est pas que je viens de créer cette
adresse e-mail juste pour pouvoir faire
cette démo
la dics tournesol
conteste
e
com
et le mot de passe
qui
écrire en clair parce que je pompe alors
utiliser du tout je me suis connecté et
là j'ai reçu un email de tournesol qui
me dit veuillez confirmer la création de
vos comptes en cliquant seniors
jacques-duclos niort
ouvrir le médiateur nerfs notre page
confirmé et voilà maintenant le compte
est maintenant confirmée et vérifiées et
du coup maintenant vous pouvez vous
connecter
du coup avec le comte tournesol
tests et avec le mot de passe qui vous
avait été donné
donc là je suis connecté en tant que
tournesol tests et à partir de ce moment
là je peux à nouveau
al farra pages de comparaison il a cette
fois je vais pour faire des comparaisons
alors juste là je vais moi c'est le
login et très classique j'espère que ça
se passe bien chez vous alors su ce que
je vais faire c'est que je vais utiliser
mon propre
avec le mot de passe
maintenant je suis connecté avec mon
propre compte sur tournesol
je vous invite à le faire chez vous a
essayé de faire la même chose à redire
même avant de commencer pour prenez le
temps par exemple en gardant cela aussi
vous pouvez ou peut-être un peu plus
tard de faire ces mêmes étapes pour en
arriver là et en arriver à cette page
qui ébranla la page où vous pouvez
contribuer quoi à tournesol peut-être
avant ça peut-être noté quelques autres
pages une autre page s'appelle la page
de recommandations donc plutôt qu'à les
voir la recommandation sur youtube.com
vous pouvez si les voir sur la page de
tournesol et vous pouvez voir que en ce
moment la vidéo numéro il est la
dernière vidéo de
dirty baloji alors qu' en ce moment
parce que là en fait si vous avez filtre
en fait les vidéos de ce mois ci
traders la vidéo
jock celle là je n'ai pas vu comment
survivre à un débat sur l'écologie
par celle là elle part en selle la gelée
vu et j'ai vu aussi dans tout cas
récemment c'est une ex en vidéo la
recommande vivement alors gelé noté roy
je crois que parmi les contributeurs
yamoy
[Musique]
hippie cette vidéo alors quand j'ai pas
vu cette vidéo et je n'ai pas noté du
coup mais on a beaucoup recommandé et
tournesol normande
qui va falloir que je vois
et william à vidéo aussi parmi les
villes et en formation c'est là aussi il
est lui passé je démonte et si je me
trompe pas et les vidéos éolien en mer
[Musique]
celle là c'est celle du réveil heures
recommandations du mois dernier beaucoup
de records nation francophone beaucoup
de francophones parmi contribuer terreur
pour l'instant c'est cette pas
surprenant
et voilà puis si vous voulez voir cette
année
y'a pas la fonctionnalité a dit à mme
aeternam depuis toujours
bon en tout cas les meilleures vidéos
d'après ton sol qu'on voit qu'il ya des
fans de ma chaîne qui ont peut-être noté
cette vidéo qui n'ont pour que je suis
d'accord avec eux je pense que c'est
vraiment la vidéo la plus importante que
j'ai fait
et puis voilà c'est là est vraiment cool
je me recommander
sur l'automatisation du racisme et les
problèmes de biais sa date de sortie
biologie à nouveau kika par m et
c'est là que j'ai fait sur qu est-ce qu
enfin pourquoi est ce que google
recommandé pourquoi ce qui est important
de comprendre pourquoi est-ce que ça
pose des problèmes
aux actes syllabus les révélations des
frontières ça gagne donc s'associe à
la vidéo mais en anglais apparemment les
mois à venir en anglais
une vidéo surprenante climatique
bon je vous laisse
explorer tout ça un peu plus tard
là j'ai envie de maintenant de passer à
la comparaison de vidéos
donc si vous avez pu
alors les lorsque vous arrivez là en
fait donc vous devez comparer deux
vidéos alors vous pouvez laisser
tournesol choisir les vidéos à comparer
une vidéo d'eux
fribourg un baume sur en plus de paysans
donc avoir parti pris mais vous avez
deux vidéos et
[Musique]
donc les deux vidéos et la grande
question c'est laquelle de ces deux
vidéos devraient être davantage
recommandé donc bon paas et saas et de
vidéos que j'ai vu moi en fait celle là
ça de gauche fait partie de moralité far
east c'est à dire que quand j'étais sur
youtube
voilà c'est si vous êtes à nouveau sur
et que je vais
leur convention du tournesol si je vais
voir
cette vidéo là
lorsque cette fois je clique sur
highlighter là cette fois ça va rajouter
la vidéo à mon compte sur sur tournesol
est en fait je peux voir la liste des
vidéos à comparer plus darmon à sa liste
à comparer plus tard sepric l'effort en
anglais un compétiteur du coup en france
est à comparer plus tard ben vous voyez
que la vidéo que je viens d'en rajouter
et là
quand je clique ray sur ce bouton
charger des vidéos sera plus
probablement sortir c'est de la vente en
gros et du coup je veux pouvoir la
comparer
[Musique]
notre vidéo et si
revenir à la comparaison de vidéos donc
si je vais à comparer des vidéos alors
soit vous pouvez laisser tournesol
générer des vidéos aussi si vous avez
aucune vidéo en traiteur libre il est
originaire et d'autres vidéos soit vous
pouvez choisir les vidéos que vous
voulez comparer rentrée l'url de des
vidéos que vous voulez comparer et en
fait je vous propose de comparer deux
vidéos que j'ai fait ça augmente la
priorité que vous avez vu je mixe vous
êtes là pour éviter non négligeable que
j'ai vu mes vidéos récentes on va dire
donc je vous propose de comparer ces
deux vidéos donc là je vais
copier-coller 2 url et en fait ça me
donne aussi une url de comparaison et
celtes url je vais la copier simplement
ici dans le
le chat et du coupé juste cliquer dessus
si vous avez un compte sur tournesol ça
va vous redirigez directement vers votre
compte vers vers la page sur laquelle je
suis du coup on peut faire la
comparaison tous france on
vous invite vivement à le faire pour
essayer de voir
ce que ça représente et
est donc entre ces deux vidéos entre
vidéo zuckerberg en prison et à vidéo
pré banking les vaccinés hospitalisés
vous devez dire laquelle de cette vidéo
s'il était à la place d'hugo
doit encore nation et que vous
connaissiez rien du tout à la personne à
qui vaut qu'en dit la vidéo laquelle de
ces deux vidéos si vous devez choisir
une vidéo a recommandé ou laquelle est
en premier a recommandé
laquelle de ces vidéos
vous pensez de voir recommander donc si
vous allez à gauche c'est que vous
pensez que celle de gauche et devrait
davantage recommander celle de la droite
c'est que celle de droite devraient être
davantage est recommandé
et en moins entre les deux
mon avis personnel entre les deux en
tout cas je pense que la vidéo gauche
est plus importante et même pas mal plus
importante
je serai peut-être là
même si la vidéo de droite je pense est
importante aussi
bah c'est d'aider des sujets un peu
rabattus je pense que celle là un peu
moins sensible bush avait jusqu'ici
et du coup aussi ici au passage plus
enregistrés et du coup maintenant la
comparaison hétéros ont été enregistrés
elle a été rajouté à la base de données
alors là a été rajoutée à base de
feuilles public parce que là j'ai mis
les vôtres notation les jugements la
vidéo ici en public
si vous voulez faire en privé basse puis
cliquez vous savez public
mais si vous faites ça publiquement du
coup la balle votre jugement vient
d'être ajouté à la base de données de
tournesol et du coup vous avez fait un
petit pas de plus vers rendre cette base
de données plus importante pour
permettre pour encourager des chercheurs
à plus de chercheurs à l étudier mais
qui devient un peu standard dont de la
recherche
[Musique]
alors le conte perdre comme ça c'est
déjà dans super donc si vous pouvez
faire ce genre de comparaison
déjà excellent et on a vraiment besoin
de beaucoup plus de ça
sachant aussi que ça aussi influencer
directement les recommandations qui vont
faire peur qui ont été faites par par
algorithmics sont au sol
en fait intuitivement quand vous dites
ça c'est comme si vous dites à tous en
soldes augmenter le score de la vidéo de
gauche et de diminuer celle de droite
pas de ce qui se passe en interne c'est
un petit peu plus un peu plus compliqué
que ça en fait ce qui va se passer c'est
que tours servent à calculer des scores
individuels donc en fait ce que ça va
faire ça va augmenter votre score
individuel pour la vidéo de gauche ça va
diminuer votre score individuel pour la
vidéo de droite est alors la manière
dont ça va le faire exactement c'est un
peu plus compliqué des histoires de
modèles un peu malaisien du machine
learning et toutes ces histoires de caen
paris sonne based learning lors je peux
mettre en valeur dans le chatt vers une
vidéo on parle un peu de sport
[Musique]
une vidéo on parle de la manière dont de
quelques modèles classiques de
machine learning pour transformer des
comparaisons comme ça en score et
ensuite lorsque vous avez des
pensionnats les scores individuels des
personnes en fait on suit va avoir un
espèce de con
bien que le juste milieu on va dire via
des tags wake est un peu qui
malheureusement est un peu plus
compliquée pour des raisons techniques
au fait pas je profite d'être trop
techniques ici mais
in fine et on peut voir ça un peu comme
un calcul de mode de médiane en gros le
score ressemble un peu à une sorte de
médiane et du coup le score d'une vidéo
donc ça passe mon jugement majoritaire
pour ceux qui connaissent le score d'une
vidéo ce sera en gros c'est pas
exactement sort mais ce sera en gros un
score quelques la moitié des personnes
des contributeurs de son insolent pense
que ce corps est trop faible
qui est l'autre moitié pense que ce
corps est trop élevé
un peu comme ça qu'on fonctionne
tournesol c'est un peu plus compliqué
que ça
est on en train justement de travailler
sur les mathématiques de ça parce qu'on
veut des bonnes propriétés en
particulier on veut que ça soit
résilient à des contributeurs
malveillants ou corrompus à votre chose
on défaut aux utilisateurs
et
c'est pour ça que
les trucs un peu plus compliqué qu'il va
me prendre un peu plus de vidéos a
expliqué malheureusement
[Musique]
ceci étant dit il ya
un autre truc sur ie sur lequel je
payais des questions et peut-être
regarder un petit peu pour retrouver des
visages jean jacques crèvecoeur alors
c'est possible de comparer des vidéos
n'importe quelle vidéo de mettre des
vidéos très mauvaise aussi
est pareil dire laquelle devrait
davantage être commandés si les scores
sont des vidéos aujourd'hui quelqu'un de
l'algo effet si les scores de la vidéo
calculé sont négatifs alors tournesol ne
les montre pas tu vas pas par défaut
et parce qu'on vous parle recommander
des vidéos mauvaise parce qu'elles ont
été partenaires en mauvaise mais ça
reste des données très importantes en
fait qu'il nous faut collecter pour
comprendre les jugements humains donc ça
reste très utile pour dans la base de
données publique de comparer des vidéos
qui sont enfin d'inclure des
comparaisons de vidéos très mauvaise
après bien sûr pour l'impact pour le
gault et des recommandations qui va
recompter les très bonne vidéo ça va
bien sûr ça a moins d'impact
alors ce qu'une autre question
[Musique]
très divertissant de type gaming est il
pertinent de comparer des vidéos très
divertissant de type gaming avec celles
déjà disponibles
oui je pense que oui après il ya des
vidéos qui sont plus ou moins
intéressant tu penses à a comparé m mais
ça me va je vais passer justement dans
les critères optionnels ou en fait la
question vraiment important de ces
caisses qui doit davantage recommandé
mais souvent dans votre comparaison
d'offres en tout cas moi personnellement
la composante j'ai envie de dire un peu
plus et d'expliquer pourquoi est-ce que
je pense qu'à vidéo de gauche doit être
davantage recommandé c'est pour ça
qu'ils les critères optionnels pour
pouvoir y arriver et parmi ces critères
optionnels boukari le fait d'être
fiables et non trompeur parce que c'est
une information fiable et non trompeuse
donc si c'est une vidéo de gaming n'y a
pas beaucoup d'informations
un sens moins fiable qu'une forme vidéo
avec beaucoup d'informations fiables
et j'insiste bien sûr sur le respect non
trompeur parce que
j'ai vu ma dernière vidéo
je parle beaucoup du fait que c'est très
facile de tromper avec des données
parfaitement factuelle donc la semaine
autres ont peur est quelque chose qu'on
concert très important dans tournesol
je vais modifier la comparaison parce
que sinon je
pourrais m'exprimer maintenant sur ses
autres critères
donc fiables et non trompeur d'ailleurs
j'aurais demandé avant de passer à ça
dans l'autre cas dans le tchat vous
pensez que laquelle enfin laquelle de
ces deux vidéos vous pensez devoir
voudriez davantage recommandé à grande
échelle est ce que vous êtes plutôt
vidéo de gauche ou de droite voekler
gauche ou droite pour votre avis ce que
vous pensez que la vidéo de gauche
devraient davantage recommandé ou est-ce
que la vidéo de droite dure et on
devrait davantage être conditionnel
choix entre les deux car nous serons pas
une seule proposition recommandations à
faire là qu'elle recommande deux rives
permettre de lire un peu les questions
pourtant vous essayer de répondre à
celle là
alors yahia coucou joule qui pose une
très bonne question qui est ce qu est ce
que le ton se leva extrapolé l'escaut
les cordes pour les des vidéos qu'il n'a
jamais vue où est ce que tous les scores
sont faits à la main donc aujourd'hui en
hausse et faire à la main sont plus
exposés plus exactement on assigne des
scores à des vidéos que si la personne a
noté la vidéo et ça c'est pour des
raisons de sécurité c'est plus facile de
prouver des théorèmes 2 que les scores
sont bien représentatif bien bien comme
on veut en faisant cela mais on aimerait
mois déjà convertis gay on y prend les
recherches mais on aimerait pousser un
peu plus la généralisation des scores
et donc il ya pas mal d'idées pour pour
le faire là toute la difficulté c'est de
faire cette façon robuste et sécurisé
mais une des approches à cette classique
c'est de se dire
si
déjà on peut essayer de prendre en
contre certes certaines métadonnées donc
par exemple si les par exemple a
constamment donné des très bonnes notes
à des vidéos de monsieur fille surprise
surprise alors la prochaine vidéo de
monsieur fit même s'il n'a pas noté on
peut se dire que probablement il va lui
donner une bonne note et vous donner un
petit plus à cette vidéo il ya le vote
le vote de l'est donc ça serait de la
génération par métadonnées et il y a des
métadonnées comme le fait que la vie la
vidéo est appartient la même chaîne qui
serait largement qui semble largement
réutilisables ça c'est une voie de
recherche un autre aspect une autre voie
de recherche c'est de faire ce qu'on
appelle du collaboratif filtering c'est
à dire on va voir sur la plateforme
tournesol est-ce qu'il ya pas des gens
qui ont systématiquement les mêmes
préférences que les et peut-être qu'ils
vont trouver un mec experts hayden et
hayden a constamment les mêmes
préférences que que les maintenant il ya
une vidéo que aydan notes et
les ne l'a pas noté alors tournesol
pourrait voir se dire c'est se passer
aujourd'hui mais peut-être dans le futur
on pourrait imaginer des algorithmes qui
se disent à bâle et va probablement aimé
cette vidéo vu que aydan lie mais il
pourrait être un peu plus sécurisé faut
passer dépendre uniquement d'une
personne de haydn et si on regarde sur
tournesol plein de gens qui ressemble à
l'est et qui est systématiquement note
de la même façon fêlée et sur une autre
vidéo et sur une vidéo données ont donné
une certaine de la vidéo alors que les
ne l'a pas noté il ya de quoi peut-être
faire cette généralisation comme ça
toute la difficulté c'est de façon ferme
où ça de façon sécurisée de faire en
sorte que un contributeur
un faux compte par exemple ne puisse pas
manipuler les scores de tournesol et en
particulier si les scores d'un individu
de tournesol
bas
qu'est ce qui empêche les gens de créer
plusieurs comptes et de mettre en avant
le contenu qui leur plaît excellente
question donc ça me va me permettre
d'aller sur mon profil si je vais sur
mon profil jouer sur mon compte il ya le
statut de l'adresse aujourd'hui qui est
considéré fiable pourquoi parce que j'ai
utilisé mon adresse de le pfl
pour y arriver et on considère que
l'adresse pfl point ch et un nom de
domaine fiable et part cela ce qu'on
entend c'est que on pense que c'est très
difficile pour quiconque de créer
énormément de faux comptes avec une
adresse e-mail a topé quel point ces
âges en particulier on suspecte le pfl
de ne pas créer plein de faux comptes at
ppf l.ch et toutes les adresses emails
qui ont cette propriété qui ont fait
confiance c'est ce qu'on appelle les
domaines fiable et donc parmi les
domaines fiable bah ya beaucoup de
domaines académiques mais aussi des
associations la limmat par exemple
et centre au point net
voilà ça c'est toutes sortes de comptes
qui ont été validés par par l'équipe de
tournesol comme étant des noms de
domaine fiable dont sens où probablement
il y aura pas beaucoup de faux comptes
qui seront créés via ces adresses mais
notre principale protection aujourd'hui
il ya vraiment cette préoccupation que
d'un côté peut-être que ça suffit pas et
de l'autre il y aurait toujours
potentiellement des noms de domaine qui
a accepté par erreur ou du soudan genre
donc moyen tard suivi des noms de
domaine qu'il qui doit être mis en place
mais également on aimerait aussi
accepter davantage de gens parce que si
on accepte que les gens de ces noms de
domaine c'est très académique souvent
si on accepte que les gens avec ses
moins un domaine on va avoir un billet
de représentation parmi l'ensemble des
contributeurs de tournesol et du coup on
en train de ça fait partie des
prochaines fonctionnalités de tournesol
et ça prend bien sûr du temps à
développer de d'avoir un système de
garde où l'on peut se poser garant pour
quelqu'un d'autre en disant je pense que
cet autre conte est un vrai compte et
que la personne derrière ce conte
n'utilise que ce compte pour contribuer
à tournesol qui va pas créer plein de
faux comptes pour manipuler tournesol
donc si vous n'avez pas une adresse
avec ce nom de domaine bas probablement
ici votre statut de l'adresse va pas
être conservés fiable et du coup donc
votre influence sur les scores de
tournesol sera très limité
pour parce qu'on cherche à se protéger
des faux comptes et d'ailleurs c'est
aussi un problème un problème de
recherche que de savoir quelle est la
meilleure façon d'utiliser ces façons de
certifier d'autres comptes pour assigner
des droits de vote qui correspondent à
la confiance qu'on a en fait les
différents comptes sont des vrais
comptes ou des faux comptes
autre problème de recherche ok je
regarde ma comparaison
attaquer d'autres questions est ce qu'un
nouveau système de validation de l'été
on en parlait comment comparer deux
vidéos mauvaise m
6 2 les deux vidéos sont mauvaises l'une
peut être quand même malgré tout bien
plus mauvaises que l'autre conquis à
mettre le curseur au centre de dire
qu'elles sont aussi mauvaises l'une que
l'autre dans cette c1 jugement après
tout l'intérêt toute l'idée c'est que en
fait tu vas voir des confédérations
petit à petit et si on peut connecter le
crac et comparaison dire que telle vidéo
et plus mauvaise que celle là qui est
puni parce que c'est là qu'ils étaient
moyennes qui est plus mauvaises que
celles la concurrence est bien qui est
plus vaste que celle là qui est
excellente ça nous permet de détrôner de
devoir ensuite dessiné des scores aux
différentes vidéos
c'est une vidéo anglaise mais traduite
et est objectivement plus qualitative
que dans tous les domaines sera at elle
recommandé ou par difficultés d'accès
par l'utilisateur serait-elle moins en
moins mis en avant donc en fait j'ai
ouvert regarder sa montre et ça mais il
est possible de filtrer les
recommandations par langue
dans les recommandations sur tournesol
vous pouvez filtrer par langue un peu
d'allemand aussi parce que on en suisse
et certains des des contributeurs sont
en suisse alémanique
si vous n'êtes que des vidéos anglais
aurait que des recommandations en
anglais et c'est possible aussi de faire
cela via l'ex de suspension
sur l'extension aussi donc sur
youtube.com si vous avez extensions
d'ailés des recommandations il vous
pouvez choisir un nombre si vous voulez
que des vidéos en français
et
la fonctionnalité développée mais il y
aura un autre truc bientôt en cliquant
sur ça pour avoir je crois que c'était
la dernière proposition des de lui
notamment pour pouvoir choisir
directement les longues ici plein de
fonctionnalités encore à développer
de rappeler que si vous êtes développeur
et que vous avez un peu de temps à vous
consacrer un projet open source
qui chercha à être d'utilité publique
n'hésitez pas à venir sur les discordes
de tournesol et vous pouvez tous les
tout ça sur la page à propos de
tournesol
bon voila quand même discrétion donc je
vous regarde un peu vous avez mis un peu
donc les réponses et qu'elle doit de
laquelle des deux devrait davantage être
aux commandes et donc on à gauche gauche
droite gauche gauche gauche droite
droite gauche gauche
droite droite droite gauche droite
gauche gauche droite gauche trois tracés
c'est partager c'est intéressant c'est
c'est intéressant
google
lorsqu'il ce qui est intéressant ce
qu'on va pouvoir détailler un peu plus
les raisons pour lesquelles on pense
gauche ou droite
du coup on peut le refaire ici on live
vous pouvez le faire également
directement sur tournesol mais on peut
le faire aussi dans le khat donc par
exemple sur l'aspect fiables et non
trompeur laquelle des deux de ces deux
vidéos vous pensez être davantage
fiables et non trompeuse
sur berg ou preventing sur les vaccinés
hospitalisé gauche ou droite qui vit
gauche qui dit droite
[Musique]
mais quelle des deux vidéos et davantage
câble et non trompeuse
d'ailleurs tournesol qui est dans le
chat c'est un vote que hayden de
secrétaire de l'association monsieur me
trompe pas
alors droite droite
qu'il faudrait peut-être dire
pourcentage je crois vous pouvez dire
droite
foule à droite plutôt à droite
ultra droite
wet ones watts droite je pense qu'on est
à peu près d'accord
en effet
[Musique]
attention ce qui se dégage en tout cas
c'est ce que je pense aussi la vidéo de
droite c'est une analyse mathématique
avec enfin
c'est une prédiction déjà qui c'est qui
qui s'est vérifiée et qui s'appuie sur
des maths et en fait la vidéo par le
même davantage de la différence entre a
profité de haas a changé d'après été de
baisser sa chambre à quai comme quelque
chose extrêmement solide au fondement du
savoir si on est balisé à un truc du
solide qui soit plus solide encore que
les mathématiques ou presque donc ouais
je crois je viens très bien à droite
alors que la vidéo de gauche elle est
pas mal documenté et à pas mal de coups
de sources des témoignages plus ça mais
ça reste fondé sur
des choses un peu moins faim des données
empiriques des lacs immenses avec eux
quelques notions mathématiques
et dans un cas plus de chances qu'elles
sont un peu trompeurs
si je bois une crédence en nombre de
choses qui se dit dans cette vidéo c'est
quand même moins fiable que la vidéo de
droite un peu moins
[Musique]
ensuite claire et pédagogique qu'est ce
que vous pensez laquelle de ces deux
vidéos et davantage claire et
pédagogique
gauche ou droite outre à gauche enfin
extrême gauche revient ultra gauche pour
ne pas faire trop politique bien à
gauche plutôt à gauche gauche gauche
plutôt à gauche milieu droite temps des
fetwas droite
droite bien au groupe double droite bien
à droite
ultra droite pour claire et pédagogique
qu'est ce que vous pensez
louis le live sera rendu le 10 sport en
replay après
alors une autre question devrait vous
ajouter par exemple trois boutons radio
pour indiquer que les deux vidéos sont
dans le au milieu ou bas des valeurs de
qualité si les deux sont mauvaises
alors oui alors oui mais en fait c'est
un des projets aussi et beaucoup de
fonctionnalités qu'on va rajouter mais
la possiblité en fait de liker ou
disloqués la vidéo
[Musique]
on pense que c'est important d'avoir des
comparaisons parce que ça permet d'avoir
un jugement plus fin et plus c'est des
données beaucoup plus informative
beaucoup plus précise mais
bien sûr la plupart des gens
pas forcément vouloir andros autant de
temps pour comparer des vidéos et puis
même pour la gauche de tournesol ça peut
être utile de savoir très rapidement si
c'est plutôt plutôt bas tout ça et j'ai
déjà des modèles mathématiques en tête
sur comment est ce qu'on peut bien lisez
façon cohérente et toutes ces données et
à ressortir des scores donc c'est une
très bonne question et je pense que ça
est une fonctionnalité enfin c'est une
fonctionner sur lesquels on travaille
déjà
qui pourra priorise c'est une question
[Musique]
or droite 80% plutôt à droite droite
gauche moyenne un peu à droite droite
25% 90% à droite 50% gauche foule droite
droite légèrement très à gauche
légèrement à gauche
un père sort pas mal de
variation
moi j'aurais dit ah je vais laisser au
milieu
c'est pas trop comment de positionner
celle celle de gauche je vais faire à un
belge que j'ai fait pas mal d'efforts
pour vraiment essayé de retracer le flux
la pensée et partant des sources et
formats avec des extraits tout ça bien
expliquer les choses alors que que celle
de droite j'ai l'impression que c'était
un petit peu plus un petit peu moins un
peu mon flux dans des explications mais
c'est un truc
[Musique]
il ya aussi l'aspect
enfin que j'aime bien que très bonne
king donc je vais laisser au milieu
parce que c'est un peu près 20 quines
versus le côté près banking fois c'était
vraiment cool donc moi je vais laisser
au milieu
ensuite il porte un acte une obole
laquelle de ces deux vidéos d'après vous
est plus importante et
actionnez vol du coup actionnable
vas-y en français
laissait actionnable en tout cas
important et actionnables
dans une des vidéos j'avais pu avait mis
important et susciter alexion prendre
actionnable important et actionnables
qu'est ce que vous pensez du coup ultra
gauche bien à gauche gauche plutôt à
gauche milieu
légèrement à droite
bien la droite droite bien à droite
ultra à droite
laquelle des deux est plus importante et
actionnables
[Musique]
gauche gauche gauche
e
gauche couscous carmon droite
plutôt à gauche droite
[Musique]
la possibilité de les descendre sur le
tchad
ah ouais je suis découvre au yes merci
sera beaucoup plus simple moi je ferai
ça pour la prochaine
[Musique]
qu'a donc ça ça penche à gauche m même
s'il ya des gens à droite
je suis désolé pour les centres
politiques c'est la rentrée politique
moi je pense bien à gauche sur ses
portes internationaux gaulle je pense
que ce qui rend la vidéo en fait à
gauche mais beaucoup plus importante
c'est que c'est un sujet
très négligée excès c'est tellement plus
important de diffuser je pense à vis de
la gauche que sa venue droite et
d'ailleurs ça me frustre pascale hebel
gauche a beaucoup moins de vue
parce que ton confondues
donc tu vois je pense très à gauche
pensent que ces questions sont très
sous-estimées et
moi entre les deux lorsque j'ai
découvert ce problème des vaccinés
spectateurs que j'ai quand même bien
flipper mais quand j'ai découvert les
facebook fasse je suis tombé des nues je
savais que c'était horrible mais c'était
bien plus horrible que ce que
j'imaginais donc moi je mettrais très à
gauche
[Musique]
on va passer aux six mois je vais mettre
le peu de que sur qui tu es et
maintenant accessible au monde
spécialistes d'ailleurs pour
bancarel sa spécialiste il faut
d'orthographe sur tournesol
alors
[Musique]
quatre options seraient du coup très à
gauche plutôt à gauche plutôt à droite
est très à droite
[Musique]
qu'est ce que je vais leur bulletin
cet avis
ok laquelle de ces deux et plus
accessible aux non spécialistes
[Musique]
et
alors du comté mieux fait remarquer ya
pas de deux unités de mesure sur les
droites on sait pas si l'expression de
notre vision et
gauche ou à droite
[Musique]
alors
un des aspect intéressant c'est que
hayden qui dans le cas tu attends ça ne
pas noter exactement la même façon il a
tendance à resserrer plus que moi je
n'ai pas prendre des trucs un peu
extrême vous avez pu le voir
et du coup ça pose un problème à gorée
qui en fait c'est une gale interprété
tout ça et apprendre comment bien après
tout ça c'est un des gros défi en fait
de la modélisation de comment est-ce
qu'on calcule des scores par individu
qui soit à la même échelle que les
scores des deux autres individus
et puis c'est en fait c'est un gros
problème de recherche
normalement on a un papier qui devrait
être
bientôt disponible dans un moment
revenir me voir me mi février
puis on verra les revues tout ça mais je
finirai sans doute par en parler sur sur
scène sole
mio hardcore mis en garde
ok donc moi ce que je vois
ok donc plutôt à gauche
moi je pense tout à fait d'accord plutôt
à gauche mais ça ça comme ça
car ce
que je peux en pole
[Musique]
g
peu du mal avec l'interface de youtube
ok tu être paul
maintenant on passe du coup à
divertissant et relaxante
peut-être que m divertissant ou relaxant
jour je dois réfléchir à ça
[Musique]
non
et très à droite
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez à ce que
laquelle de ces deux vidéos et plus
divertissante et relaxante
redire divertissante surtout puisque
relaxant je pense que les deux sont
assez
[Rires]
je veux pas trop dans le relaxant
[Musique]
divertissant et relaxant
plutôt à gauche
14h20 ça
s'adresse plutôt
droite
[Musique]
qui est plutôt gauche
moi je mettrais plutôt gauche aussi
c'est quand même
à dire divertissant de voir à qui le
pensent et demi heure
on va dire ça
[Musique]
ok prochain
sondage
l'arrivée m tu me permets
stimulant et relaxant
l'attrait gauche
plutôt gauche
[Musique]
plutôt droite
très droite
on
[Musique]
stimulant et suscite la réflexion à
laquelle de ces vidéos fait réfléchir et
et
pique la curiosité donne envie d'en
savoir plus
tant parlé avec d'autres
[Musique]
oscar demandait ce que tournesol
permettre un avis sur une vidéo jamais
comparer
donc j'aurais parlé un peu plus tôt du
coup j'ai pas trop développées mais la
réponse en gros aujourd'hui c'est non
parce qu'on n'a pas réussi à galérer à
concevoir les algorithmes pension
aujourd'hui pour qu'ils soient sécurisés
et faire de la généralisation de façon
sécurisée c'est encore un peu plus
difficile nous pensons on l'a fait la
version simple est ce qu'on espère c'est
que des chercheurs s'empareront déjà
nous on va s'emparer de cette question
mais que d'autres chercheurs également
vont s'emparer de ces questions
d'ailleurs ça me permet de faire à
nouveau un appel si vous êtes chercheur
dans le domaine en plus que dire plus en
mathématiques même encore que en
informatique 34 ans à tiko rich
et que ce sujet vous intéresse et goujon
en savoir plus mais aussi des problèmes
de développement si ces choses nous
intéresse ou s'il est psychologue aussi
de très sûr encoder des
modéliser la psyché humaine et faisant
genre bah n'hésitez pas à vous
intéresser à tous au sol à lire tout ce
qu'on a écrit et et puis si jamais une
collaboration nous intéresse
c'est clairement je perçois m'en
foutrais débordé dès jamais
plein de projets de recherche à partager
merci viola trad
[Musique]
e
voilà donc les résultats du coup plutôt
à gauche fait davantage réfléchir la
vidéo de gauche
passait légèrement mais oui parce que
c'est le droit dossier
chercher en tout cas suscité pas mal la
réflexion mais peut-être celle de gauche
un peu plus
pas beaucoup plus
suivant
[Musique]
youtube
un petit délai à chaque fois et youtube
donc le suivant c'est diversité
et l'inclusion
[Musique]
près gauche plutôt gauche
plutôt droite
très droite
je dois dire aussi si vous voulez en
savoir plus vous pouvez toujours cliquer
sur
sur les noms des critères donc ça sera
un autre onglet et
il ya la description de chacun des
critères
clairement faire déverser téninkou
jeunes
alors une version française aussi des
outils
sap a été traduit le coeur
[Musique]
traduire si vous voulez contribuer aussi
c'est une façon de contribuer contribuez
oui qui en donnait mettre à jour à tout
ça et à la traduction
c est ce qu on promeut la diversité vite
et est ce que ça la vidéo va être bien
reçues
genre de choses
ce qu'elle est
prendre la diversité et l'inclusion et
donc là où vous êtes très à gauche je
fais tout à fait d'accord
on est là pour
pour les ans devant ti'vac sont à dire
celle de droite et pas forcément facile
à
écoutez et puis celle de gauche parle
beaucoup de choses quatre coins du monde
je ne suis de
homard
l'ethiopie
ce qui est encore
trafic du mans
voit même pas mal de choses
bien à gauche on
ensuite en courage de mes hobbies
l'habitude
[Musique]
à
gauche
droite
très droite
[Musique]
laquelle de ces deux vidéos encourage de
meilleures habitudes zuckerberg ou free
banking sur les vaccinés hospitalisé
[Musique]
m
et quelle vidéo
c'est très partagés très clivant
[Musique]
entre ces deux vidéos ça penche à droite
là je suis d'accord je penserai à droite
aussi
pas ils n'ont voici quand même
[Musique]
celle de droite c'est vraiment un
encouragement à faire attention à la
praille était de s achever la suisse a
pour idée de pessalle chan a pour moi
c'est vraiment le truc important bas
prix ya aussi le fait de se vacciner et
donc aux régions à se vacciner mais
c'est vraiment plus cet aspect de se
méfier de ça parce que c'est elle que
j'ai pensé alors c'était pas vraiment
l'impact que ça va voir l'autre aile et
les deux sont sous quelque chose de très
important et de traits ses bonnes
habitudes à prendre
on peut réfléchir à tout ça alors que
celle de gauche là le défaut est
d'encourager la vue l'habitude de se
plaindre et de s'indigner
même si elle encourage aussi à qu'elle
cherche à encourager les gens à
s'informer beaucoup plus régulièrement
sur ces sujets et à
bath les chercheurs ou développeurs tout
ça pendant un peu plus position sur ce
genre de sujets
ou être plus critique en tout cas de
tous ces technologies parce que c'est
aussi une bonne habitude à prendre
[Musique]
on
et enfin le dernier donc résistants
au retour négatif
[Musique]
ted
béchir un peu l'appellation suspect
idéal
lorsqu'on entend par là c'est
est ce que les gens vont mal interprété
les choses et ça fait un retour de bâton
et
ils vont mettre
avoir compté quelque chose de traverse à
les renforcer dans des convictions qui
sont pas vraiment le message de la vidéo
c'est un peu ça ce qu'on entend par par
cette chose parce qu'avoir une réac
temps ce qu'ils veulent on préfère
qu'ils vont encore plus rejeter la vidéo
et confortés dans leur opinion c'est un
peu
un ce dernier critère qui l'a
existants au retour négatif
[Musique]
clé de ces deux vidéos et plus
résistante euros
pour retourner à tifo autour de bâton
des mécontents sion avait
des indignations injustifiées ou à des
quelque chose qui ne passe pas on va
dire
c'est très étalée également sa reine est
très à gauche et à droite
avant je dirais quand même
donc quoi bon moi moi alors j'ai pas lu
énormément et commentaires mais j'ai
aussi vu survoler un peu les
commentaires break car en salle deux
kits de droite et le sujet des vaccins
est vraiment délicat
il ya beaucoup de mes compréhension
il ya aussi un risque avec la vidéo doha
que les gens retiennent pas forcément le
ce que j'aimerais qu'ils retiennent on
va dire
mémoire avec l'âme intéressante aussi de
passe il me suis pas fait comme à gauche
parce que
j'ai l'impression que vidéo droite c'est
plus facile d'avoir une réac temps ces
deux puis les probabilités c'est facile
d'avoir
parce que c'est
forêts
je pensais peut-être un peu moins bonne
comme ça
voilà on va terminer pour ça ça prend du
temps de juger de façon aussi
collaboratif ça prend un peu ça
programme du temps de noter selon tous
les critères
donc
je trouve que c'est un exercice qui est
vraiment intéressant de noter selon tous
les critères
notamment parce que bien souvent quand
je regarde un peu ce hors
jeu
je peux faire le bilan un petit peu me
dit ah bon parce que j'ai bien fait de
le placer la
sec en voyant ça j'ai envie de dire que
c'était un peu trop loin peut-être que
jaro déplacer ici mais clairement le la
raison pour laquelle je pencher à gauche
c'est ses rangs ce critère c'est que le
sujet de gauche pour me semble me semble
beaucoup plus important
tout s'est intéressé en tout cas de nous
était tous les critères ça permet de
vraiment se demander si j'ai vraiment
réfléchi à tout ce qui importe dans la
vidéo
alors je vais même encore un peu plus
fort donc c'est vraiment inutilisés mais
bien sûr ça prend plus de temps et donc
j'insiste à nouveau
c'est largement déjà très bien de juin
seul critère c'est ça fait déjà des
données très utiles le fait d'avoir
toutes les données c'est vrai que c'est
encore plus intéressant mais un peu au
calme en toutes les données qu'on peut
avoir aujourd'hui c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui va vraiment enrichir
la connaissance humaine sur comment est
ce qu'on fait des jeux en question les
vidéos à reconnaître et tout ça et ça
motive énormément de recherche donc
j'insiste j'encourage encore chacun
d'entre vous à fournir des jugements
même si vous avez votre compte n'est pas
encore passée avait certifié on espère
avoir ce graphe de garant plus tard qui
nous permet de certifier +2 contre
qu'équipe qui vont accélérer la
recherche et quelques on aura des façons
de facilement identifier des conclusions
moins fiables ont réfléchi à tout ça en
tout cas en tout cas dès aujourd'hui
toutes les données surtout si vous les
mettez publiquement c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui va vraiment motivé la
recherche que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de très important je pense pour
concevoir des algorithmes beaucoup plus
éthique et sécurisé à ce que les
questions de sécurité devienne évidente
quand on parle de ça quand on parle de
traitement 2 d'image de reconnaître
trois dans une image comprend que les
questions de sécurité sont pas
folichons c'est vraiment des questions
performance en fait les raisons de
sécurité mais là là quand on est là
comme ça et qu'on s'appuie sur des
données fournies par des des
contributeurs pour ne connais pas
personnellement la question de la
sécurité de dire tout de suite beaucoup
plus critique beaucoup plus évidente et
ça motive beaucoup de recherche donc je
vous encourage et encore une fois à
contribuer de toutes les manières vous
pouvez dernière manière dont j'ai pas
parlé c'est de faire des dons il ya une
partie faire un don ici
donc
équipe au casque était passé pas encore
passé
qui donc vous pouvez faire des dons ou
par virement direct donc à l'association
tournesol donc ça c'est notre
liban du du compte bancaire de
l'association en francs suisses vous
pouvez aussi donner via paypal et on a
aussi une page you type qui s'appelle
multiplient aux sages tournesol
[Musique]
ban
deux abonnés
tournesol dont vous pouvez faire un don
directement sur youtube et pour
ce avoir souffert de cet argent en fait
il nous sert points sans surtout ici
ils sont surtout utilisés pour les
salaires des employés de l'association
donc on est très transparent et très
transport avec vous j'ai déjà mis au
total
j'ai pas tout suivi mais enfin au moins
30 minutes je crois que c'est plus long
et 40 mille francs
que j'ai donné à l'association de façon
parfois plus ou moins direct mais
essentiellement pour payer des
développeurs
30 30 milles pour le développement parce
que ça prend des ressources
tous été dépensés en corner mais
les salaires développeurs quelque chose
de très important parce que ça prend des
ressources enfin ça prend des ingénieurs
de top qualité on a vraiment la chance
d'avoir des ingénieurs de top qualité et
qui sont parfaitement alignés avec le
projet qui comprennent vraiment les les
enjeux etc c'est vraiment rare d'avoir
déjà des développeurs de thau qualité
non plus qu'ils nous prennent tous ces
gens et qui sont motivés par la mission
éthique de
tournesol et
il faut il faut faut payer
il faut payer les gens et dire qu'on les
paye
le déroulement speer par rapport à la
suisse en tout cas
c'est pas vraiment lance pierre non plus
mais bon
on l'appelle pas comme des ingénieurs
suisses qui travailleront suisse du tout
donc il ya des sacrifices mais du coup
on a vraiment besoin de deux d'argent
pour tous pour soutenir tout ça et
l'autre aspect c'est de promouvoir
tournesol parce que
le succès tout comme ça c'est vraiment
la qualité et la quantité de données on
public notamment aussi primé mais aussi
surtout public qui on veut dire qu'on a
claqué on aura quatre collecter et qu'on
collecte
et pour cela il faut promouvoir
tournesol faut que plus de gens morts et
entendu de parler de soi que ce soit
beau plus normal
voire tournesol d'utiliser console de
recommander tournesol est ce qu'on
aimerait notamment ses des partenariats
avec des créateurs de contenu qui en
gros promeuvent tournesol dans leurs
vidéos depuis un placement de produits
éthiques pour tournesol et pour ceux là
bas c'est la même chose les créateurs de
contenu c'est des gens qui
produisent enfin sur twitter de contenus
utiles publics notamment ceux qui sont
au top du classement tournesol ses rangs
des gens qui font un travail d'utilité
publique et je pense que c'est une
excellente chose de les soutenir de ne
pas les exploiter et donc à ce que
j'aime à ce qui est vraiment un budget
qu'on connaît pour pouvoir re
payer les gens pour qu'ils recommandent
tournesol la soie à la fois dans la
francophonie mais également au delà une
typiquement c'est ici donc veritas yom
course que ça qu'elle pouvait parler de
tournesol ça pourrait changer
complètement le
futur du projet le potentiel du projet
on va dire le quantité de données qu'on
collecte en particulier et du coup
on aimerait vraiment avoir un budget
pour pour faire cela et donc vos dons ne
serait pas inutile
voilà donc quelques autres choses avant
de finir ce stream au peuple son courage
au moins créer un compte et c'est de
fournir des comparaisons
voilà quelques autres pages
donc vous pouvez voir la liste des
composants que vous avez faite sur
tournesol et pouvez les modifier si vous
n'êtes pas content vous pouvez revenir
sur un des trucs les ya en fait
on peut modifier je vais pas au métier
vous pouvez voir la liste des vidéos
comparer que vous avez comparé
ce qu'on va avoir bientôt assez des
pages utilisateurs avec les
recommandations individuelle faite à
partir des scores juste de l'utilisateur
on va voir ça encore une fois à
développer
dans la liste des vidéos à comparer plus
tard c'est une vidéo que j'avais déjà
beaucoup
comparez vous pouvez enlever delà de
cette liste est ce que ça va faire c'est
que ça va moins vous demander de la
recommander quand vous cliquez sur le
bouton charger une nouvelle vidéo art
com - à comparer dans les pages de
comparaison à pied sur ce bouton ça va
plus probablement sortir une vidéo de
votre liste de vidéos a comparé ces
melons enlevé de la liste doit charger
et je suis fait le tour du site
super donc voilà je passe il ya d'autres
questions pour terminer mais sinon à une
catégorie sport
pour parler des ces vidéos sports
divertissement et nous sommes donc dit
les critères qui correspond un peu à ça
mais je pense qu'en fait on a fait céder
je pense que c'est très important de
comparer des vidéos de divertissement de
sport enfin bon c'est important que des
vidéos
ultra important de dire quand toi c mais
ça reste important et surtout des vidéos
comme
typiquement le dernier film que j'ai vu
je regarde beaucoup de films mais
c'était a pas si longtemps c'est donc
ton cup et dans tout cas c'est un film
dont on peut je pense jugez pas mal
selon différents critères à ce que est
ce que pardon dans tout cas avait
quelque chose de deux fiables et non
trompeur parce que en partie parce que
c'est non trompeur
je pense qu'à des aspects dedans tout
cas qui sont trompeuses ton trompeur
mais il ya quand même beaucoup d'aspects
qui sont pas si troupes afin qu'ils sont
loin d'être trompeur qui révèle pas mal
de choses
voilà on peut se demander si dans tout
cas p est claire et pédagogique
vincent s'il est plus claire et
pédagogique que beaucoup de vidéos que
je fais fondre car beaucoup
d'explications du problème des
désinformations ciron ça très bon gré de
se demander si c'est un sujet important
et actionnables quelques dents tout
coeur parle quand même beaucoup la crise
de l'information quelque chose sur
lequel chacun d'entre nous agissons à
notre échelle et sur lequel il ya des
preuves de régulation sont en outre à
déployer à grande échelle donc si je
pense que c'est un sujet très important
qui ait abordé également lmg que le
changement climatique et or c'est donc
de tous les critères en tête mais voilà
tout ça pour dire que même des ddd
des sujets culturels en fait parfois ont
des implications majeures et puis
inverse d'autres d'autres films sont web
par exemple ce que je dis souvent c'est
que si si si je vais comparer terminator
et harry potter
bat je pense que harry potter et moins
trompeur que que terminator et
terminator cause beaucoup de
mal une certaine manière en donnant une
image très erronée de ce qu'est le
danger des algorithmes connaissance donc
je pense que en l'absence terminator
nous donne une image monde qui est très
trompeuse donc très comparé à harry
potter harry potter et ses compères si
certaine manière mais c'est beaucoup
enfin c'est beaucoup plus clair que
c'est un monde imaginaire que c'est il y
avait très peu dire avec
et donc si je les compare les deux je
dirais que harry potter est beaucoup
plus fiable et non trompeur que
terminator et je pense que selon
différents critères comme ça à part des
vidéos de sport
il y avait pas mal de vidéos de sport
je perds un tuto
plutôt ski tennis par exemple je sais
pas c'est encouragent le meilleur
habitude faire du sport par exemple ça
peut être du divertissement relaxant que
certaines vidéos
d'autres sports
les vidéos de foot que je trouve pas
forcément vu que je regarde quand même
alors après ça peut être divertissant et
relaxant
je pense qu'il ya quand même de quoi
juger selon ces différents critères en
tout cas de répondre à la principale
question laquelle de ces deux vidéos
devraient être davantage recommandé
mais non regarde
regarde pas terminator jeu
la façon dont la gaude et son message va
me faire des recommandations ne
sera-t-il pas trop proche de celle de
youtube ne faudrait-il pas augmenter les
sources que des lignes dessinées
dailymotion et m'a dit c'est ok
alors
aujourd'hui tournesol comparé des vidéos
sur youtube parce qu'on pense que c'est
le gros du trafic et sur youtube
aujourd'hui énormément de plus de trafic
sur youtube donc si un algo et de
recommandations 1 modifié à montrer qu'à
un algo et de monique de refondation qui
prêtent bien mieux conçus sellal go et
de l'opération de youtube parce que
c'est lui qui a le plus influent hans
lago et de reconversion de youtube j'en
veux dire il tue énormément de vie fins
et les choses pour ibles qui se passe
sur youtube la désinformation de l'appel
à la haine des génocides qui sont
organisées sur youtube il ya vraiment
des trucs horribles sur youtube et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est beaucoup plaint
du tube est beaucoup plus important et
corrigée pour ça que je pense que tourne
sol doit s'adresser beaucoup plus
youtube après ayant quelques et enfin
c'est toujours un coût en terme de
développement enfin bien sûr on pourra
remplacer chacune de ses vidéos par une
vidéo un url
dailymotion ou ou odyssey ou au pire tu
es donc ce que vous voulez
le ou même netflix on pourrait rajouter
netflix le problème avec ça c'est que ça
ça demande du temps de développement et
le temps développement ça coûte très
très cher et c'est très difficile on a
un an de 2 2 d'autres fonctionnalités à
prioriser
donc comme ça je pense que l'objectif de
tournesol c'est vraiment cette base de
données publique et je pense que ce sera
beaucoup plus efficace de cibler les
vidéos youtube pour y arriver et si on
pense que ça pourrait avoir un
changement beaucoup plus profond
moi personnellement je pense que j'ai
tendance à a vraiment pensé qu'il faut
vraiment ciblé sur youtube pour
l'instant ceci étant dit on est
justement en train de travailler sur
l'extension de tournesol à d'autres
choses parce que on la compare des
vidéos youtube donc pas comparer des
livres pourrait comparer des podcasts
et en fait on a un projet c'est un peu
un teaser c'est la chance mais la
pression nous mêmes mais on a un peu un
projet pour comparer des candidats à la
présidentielle collier de comparer deux
vidéos n'ai pas comparé aux vrais accros
mélenchon ou avec les crèches bouge pas
trop
et il y aura des critères différents le
critère principal ça serait bien sûr qui
devrait être président
et puis on peut imaginer et critères
suivants qui pourrait être par exemple
qui a la meilleure politique sociale qui
leur politique économique qui a une
heure politique internationale quelle
union politique environnementale
et ainsi de suite et c'est un projet sur
lequel on travaille
[Musique]
donc je pense qu'on peut conclure sa une
que
des questions mais ils ont déjà été
répondu
oui il ya un guide we wanted robe
tout ça c'est sur la page d'accueil de
tournesol ou sur la page à propos plutôt
de tournesol vous pourrez retrouver tout
ça sur ce je vais conclure ce live vous
remercie de votre présence et j'espère
que vous avez aimé cette introduction
que ça vous tue un petit peu
utilisé vous même en parler autour de
vous à promouvoir tournesol j'espère que
ça clarifier pas mal des choses que
autour de tournesol avec qui aura tous
ont beaucoup d'autres vidéos à venir sur
sur tournesol
comme le fait remarquer à nice lors à
financer une plateforme de vote c'est
vraiment ça et en fait je pense qu'il
faut voir les algorithmes comme des
systèmes de vote et il ya plein de
choses intéressantes sans doute à faire
à partir de là mais on fait quand vous
avez compris on attire énormément de
travail il ya beaucoup trop de choses à
faire
mais du coup toutes sortes dead ça
serait plus que bienvenu et sur ce je
vous dis bonne soirée
quand il dit bon appétit en effet je
vais bientôt manger donc bon appétit et
à bientôt sur sur scène ce soir